the crime crisis overtaking more of
america's major cities 16 of them now
reporting a record number of homicides
for the year
places like atlanta portland philly all
smashing records
in fact the city of brotherly love saw
524 murders since january
all this as liberal leaders rethink
defunding the police with some now
refunding in the face of intense
pressure
you know these these images that we've
been seeing the last couple of days uh
have been truly amer or weeks uh months
years now i guess uh are pretty amazing
but obviously it's reached a critical
mass of sorts alicia um but you know
this is quite a quite a turnaround from
you know defunding the police and
celebrating riots and and uh you know
vice president kamala harris uh
springing bail money to get rioters out
of jail it's it's uh quite a turnaround
isn't it it really is and it's really
interesting to watch what's happening in
california right now with now
the governor there just throwing what
300 million dollars toward fighting
crime there you have the mayor of san
francisco also saying enough is enough
these are leaders who had a very
different point of view and a very
different tone um not too long ago and
it's also interesting it'll be
interesting to see the way the coverage
plays out that you know so often we hear
from many leaders that this is pandemic
related but now folks are starting to
say and really starting to take a look
um at whether or not that's true that
that may in fact be part of it but that
is not all of it that there are other
problems at play here other things going
on
yeah well you know democrats made it
famous about you know never let a crisis
go to waste well we'll never let a good
uh never let a good excuse uh go unused
far too much probably more than uh you
they ought to be using it uh joe check
out this uh this is a store owner out in
san francisco and this is just how
desperate the situation is to the point
where you've got these people they're
actually sleeping in their own stores in
order to protect them listen to this wow
i've seen in my store for the
last six days
you know because i'm scared that these
people are coming back again and uh do
the same thing because they they knew
we can always get away with this
you know joe uh just because i've been
in the media my entire life i like to
blame the media for absolutely
everything because i'm pretty sure
they're responsible for everything
but
is it possible to overdo that i mean
you know what is the media's role what
has been the media's role in all of this
and what have they done to make it worse
well charlie media's such a broad uh
word right and i think on the local
level you don't see a lot of people
complaining about the media because on
the local level at least opinions aren't
thrown into the reporting on your
30-minute newscast you see every night
right they're reporting the news uh if
someone breaks into a store they're
smash and grab or somebody is murdered
or stabbed or attacked then that will be
presented uh without opinion then you
get your weather you get your sports
scores and then that's that's the end of
your broadcast so local media if you
watch it in these cities
they've been covering this stuff and
they've been covering it well because
you don't have the gas bags on the air
telling you that it isn't happening or
people promoting people like alexandria
ocasio-cortez the congresswoman who
literally denies that this is happening
despite what you're seeing on your
screens and that's what journalism now
has become that even when you try to
spin this there are cameras everywhere
and social media makes this stuff go
viral in a hurry so
any politician sees this they can't deny
it's happening or downplay it because
the images are the images and look gavin
newsom
throwing all this money at the problem
now this has nothing to do with him
suddenly morphing into clint eastwood
right it has to do with the fact that
the governor knows how to read polls
right charlie and when it was
fashionable to march with black lives
matter or relax bail laws or cut funding
to police newsom and so many others were
right at the front of the line and now
crime threatens their power because even
their shrinking base is fed up with it
so now it's time to act like they care
about the problem but here's the problem
police forces now you talk to cops they
are demoralized across the country you
see resignations going through the roof
and criminals and felons they're
emboldened it's too little too late for
gavin newsom and these other democratic
leaders to talk tough because we know
otherwise we saw the movie in 2020.
yeah that that's a great point uh you
know and i you couldn't have said a
better uh you know gavin newsom is
definitely no uh john wayne tammy as a
recovering democrat or a recovering
liberal i think you have a always have a
unique
insight into the mind of of people when
when you're talking about and i'm not
talking about the people like gavin
newsom i'm talking about voters democrat
or liberal-leaning voters do they want
this murder in mayhem in their in their
neighborhoods
well obviously not and what's
interesting is i think that they
believed that a lot of that rhetoric was
just rhetoric for a campaign that it
would never happen right and so then
people vote you know down the line when
they're on a ticket right and then they
just go about their business
but that is the most dangerous thing for
politicians to do is to
lie to the population and to have it
become so apparent right away on issues
that affect those local small businesses
right the safety of people in their own
homes being able to go to a park
all of that you know this is these are
things that they can't lie about joe's
point is great about also social media
if they could just like what they're
doing at the border if they could keep
images away from you they would but in
this case they can't so when you're
looking at california and i think here's
what's happened when you hear the london
breed of san francisco and gavin newsom
this is an indication i think of the
democratic party nationally realizing
this is a terrifying real reality and
that they're going to get blown out next
year unless they suddenly reverse
themselves and i think the this comes
down this is these are orders from
washington uh newsome and london breed
really don't believe it and so what's
even scarier is if they didn't get that
order you guys
this would continue on even with the
destruction in every city and i think it
goes down to the background of what i
experienced on the left is that there is
a genuine malevolence toward the average
american toward this country and what we
stand for and we've got another year to
have to deal with it but i think we're
making some headway here
they they are wildly out of touch even
from their own voters hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else